I get jealous because everyone gets to
bond and have fun and get drunk we
should make you a tequila brownie a
tequila brownie how is that different
where is that a joke no no you know you
like
cake so I've pounded your mom's rum cake
oh that was a very weird sentence can we
rephrase that in a different way please
cut that I ate your mom's rum cake my
mom made rum cake that you've tried
that's right they ate like half of it
all I hear is the sexual kind of yeah
how was her mom's rum cake it was
awesome it was delicious get you [__]
up what no I ate half of it not gonna
get [__] up at all but you can taste
the rum is it tequila like that I'm just
[__] around I knew it you [__]